bonsoir vous voyez cette pierre avec
cette pierre je peux faire plein de
choses je peux jouer avec je peux casser
des choses je peux la lancée même jeu
peut détruire ou alors je peux
construire
je peux construire une maison je peux
même construire une cathédrale
le numérique c'est un peu comme cette
pierre c'est un outil avec lui je peux
choisir de détruire ou bien de
construire
moi je crois que le numérique ça peut
nous aider à construire une nouvelle
forme de démocratie et c'est ce qu'on a
fait ici au plan local à toulouse avec
une démarche d'innovation ouverte
citoyens et smart cities la smart city
c'est quoi d'abord smart ça veut dire
quoi
on dit que ça veut dire intelligent en
chine on a construit une smart city elle
est super rebelle
elle est grande avec des grands
buildings tout brillant plein de miroir
c'est ultra connectés c'est très moderne
c'est une vraie image de science fiction
seulement quand on la regarde de près on
s'aperçoit qu'il manque quelque chose
en fait la personne de dans cette ville
on l'a construite d'abord et puis on
mettra les gens dedans après en fait si
on écoute les grandes firmes avec la
smart cities finalement la ville c'est
une ville technocentre et ben moi je
crois que l'intelligence c'est pas ça
l'intelligence est de concevoir la ville
de demain avec les gens qui vivent
aujourd'hui qu'ils vivront avec l'aide
évidemment d'experts d'acteurs publics
et d'acteurs privés
c'est ce qu'on a fait ici à toulouse
avec une grande démarche d'intelligence
collective
vous savez ce que c'est l'intelligence
collective vous savez ce que c'est vous
en avez entendu parler c'est un peu en
fait c'est un peu comme une cathédrale
pas comme une cathédrale comme une
chorale j'y suis déjà la cathédrale
c'est comme une chorale en fait on a des
chanteurs et puis on a
de coeur six chefs de choeur est bon à
un moment donné au dessus de la voix des
chanteurs on va entendre une autre voix
c'est une voie qui est au dessus c'est
pas la voix des chanteurs c'est autre
chose c'est une voie qui est puissante
qui vibrante qui vient vous prendre les
tripes
on l'appelle la voix de l'ange une voix
plus une voix égale trois voies en fait
la troisième voie c'est celle du groupe
l'intelligence collective c'est un peu
pareil une intelligence plus une
intelligence égal 3 intelligence quand
on fait travailler les gens ensemble il
ya une troisième intelligence key celle
du groupe
concrètement comment ça se passe
en fait on a trois étapes 1 ou est ce
qu'on a envie d'aller ensemble
2 comment on va pouvoir y aller ensemble
et puis trois bars à trois on y va donc
la première étape
on va essayer de poser une vision
commune de notre avenir
elle ressemble à quoi cette ville de
demain dans laquelle on a envie de vivre
alors là on a réuni une centaine de
personnes de participants il y avait des
citoyens sans plus habitants on avait
avec nous des experts des acteurs
publics et des acteurs privés
il ya des experts qui nous permettent de
donner du contexte il nous apporte des
connaissances quand on en a besoin parce
qu'évidemment on a des moments on se
pose des questions on n'a pas toujours
les réponses
et puis à des facilitateurs à toutes les
tables qui aide les gens à travailler il
ya un grand pilote qui donne toutes les
consignes au fur et à mesure parce
qu'évidemment une méthode très structuré
qui permet d'arriver à la fin avec du
résultat alors les gens aux tables
discute dialogue
ils débattent parfois ils sont pas
d'accord on arrive toujours au bout du
compte aller mettre d'accord et puis le
produisent au bout d'un moment on
commence à voir cette vision qui prend
forme qui devient visible parce qu'elle
est prototype est allé maquetter elle
est dessinée sur des grands posters ou
alors les gens racontent cette histoire
et on les filme il ya des scénarios et
où il ya des maquettes
on a même fait une expérience on a mis
des écrans à toutes les tables
et c'est cet écran là il était il nous
permettait d'être en lien avec une
communauté de deux participants
dématérialisée en fait c'était des vrais
gens n'hésitez pas avec nous ils nous
envoyaient
toutes leurs tout leur contribution
comme s'ils envoyaient des post it et
des post-it apparaissait comme ça sur
les écrans et ça a très bien marché
parce qu'on a pu comme ça avoir une plus
grande communauté de participants à la
fin finalement ses visions là nous en
montrer que évidemment la vision des
citoyens de la ville de demain c'est pas
celle des grandes firmes
c'est une vision qui est centré sur
l'humain une vision qui est
intergénérationnel une ville qui va être
plus à vélo qu'en voiture une ville où
les voix de des voies d'eau redeviennent
des voies de transport
c'est une ville où la nature est
l'urbanisation vivent en harmonie c'est
une ville où le lien social à une place
absolument centrale c'est une ville où
il fait bon vivre
finalement c'est une ville intelligente
et vivante pas comme la ville chinoise
deuxième étape on a maintenant qu'on a
la vision on va aller regarder quelles
sont les étapes pour arriver à la
concrétisation de cette vision
alors là évidemment sur le chemin on va
rencontrer des obstacles qui va falloir
relever des défis qu'il va falloir
relever on va aussi avoir des soutiens
et on va avoir des ressources là le
travail c'est le même on est toujours
avec les mêmes participants avec des
gens qui vont les aider à travailler
ensemble et le but du jeu c'est d'avoir
à la fin d un cahier des charges qui va
nous permettre de faire de la recherche
de solutions parmi les ressources qu'on
va utiliser
on va avoir des technologies à des start
up qui viennent nous aider on peut avoir
des compétences des expertises des gens
qui viennent mais on a aussi des données
la date à la fameuse date à date à ckoi
finalement c'est ce sont nos traces
finalement partout où on va on passe non
avec nos téléphones nos ordinateurs nos
voitures tous nos objets connectés nos
montres maintenant bientôt nos
chaussures
partout où on passe on laisse des traces
numériques les organisations les et
trace les objets connectés tout seul
laisse des traces d'ailleurs et donc ces
données là sont dans un espèce de grand
nuage qu'on appelle le big data est en
fait dans le big data on a des données
qui sont confidentiels qui sont privées
celles là on n'y touche pas et puis il
ya des données qui sont ouvertes qui
sont publiques on appelle l'open data
ils ont appris l'open data et on l'a on
la donne et réutilisées à nos
participants pour qu'ils puissent venir
henry
scheer leurs ressources et également
leurs sources d'inspiration
troisième étape les solutions alors là
on va faire un grand marathon
d'innovation avec toujours les mêmes
personnes qu'on va aider énormément tout
est structuré et à la fin de ces deux
jours de marathon
les gens auront produit des projets
l'idée c'est que il fasse prendre forme
à des projets qui leur permette de
concrétiser la vision qu'ils ont eu au
départ ces projets là à la fin ils vont
prendre dans la forme de prototype de
maquettes qu'on va pouvoir ensuite
développé et comme on a embarqué les
parties prenantes dès le début les
acteurs publics les acteurs privés les
experts eh bien on va pouvoir les
développer beaucoup plus facilement
parce que tout le monde était là dès le
départ impliqué ils vont avoir envie de
développer les projets lorsqu'on a fait
au niveau local
on l'a aussi développer au niveau
national sur le sujet du changement
climatique
et là ça a tellement bien marché
finalement que les ministères se sont
saisis du processus et il continue
l'expérience
comme quoi les politiques peuvent
utiliser des nouveaux procédés
alors moi j'ai envie de vous poser une
question finalement quel monde
est ce qu'on veut pour nous pour nos
enfants et pour nos petits enfants parce
que ce qu'on a utilisé au niveau local
et au niveau national on peut l'utiliser
pour une nouvelle forme de démocratie
en fait la combinaison de l'intelligence
collective et du digital
ça peut nous permettre de créer une
démocratie directe et collaborative
pourquoi direct aujourd'hui
techniquement rien ne nous empêche de
pratiquer la démocratie directe
on a déjà des plates formes de
démocratie participative qui nous
permettent de mettre en place des
budgets participatifs qui nous
permettent de mettre en place du vote en
ligne
on a des applications qui nous
permettent de faire de la concertation
en ligne on a tout ce qu'il faut tout
techniquement c'est possible on a nos
réseaux sociaux évidemment qui nous
permettent de faire des pétitions alors
c'est pas toujours écoutés pour
l'instant on a tous nos réseaux sociaux
qui nous permettent aussi de d'échanger
de partager de communiquer sur tout ce
qui se passe dans l'espace public
techniquement rien ne nous empêche de
demain de créer une plateforme digitale
ou avec des processus d'intelligence
collective on pourra poser une vision
d'ensemble des citoyens qui viendront
poser sur cette plateforme leur vision
de l'avenir un projet de société et
également tous les moyens de réaliser ce
projet de société un programme un
programme d'action c'est possible et
ensuite évidemment pour venir abonder
dans cette danse est dans ses solutions
et ses projets on pourra créer les lois
proposées les lois c'est déjà possible
aujourd'hui on peut proposer des lois
ensemble voter ses doigts et puis
pourquoi pas imaginer les moyens de
faire respecter ses lois par tous
aujourd'hui cette nouvelle forme de
démocratie on l'a testé au plan local ça
marche on l'a testé au plan national ça
marche et demain matin on peut très bien
imaginer au plan mondial
pourquoi pas vous voyez cette pierre
finalement nous citoyens on a notre
future entre nos mains on peut la
construire cette cathédrale
chacun amène sa pierre et on peut bâtir
ce monde cathédrale dont on rêve
un monde où la technologie et le
numérique reste service de l'humain
un monde où la diversité est protégé et
même encouragé un monde où le lien
social reste au centre des
préoccupations et de la vie un monde où
le bonheur redevient la quête pas
seulement de chaque individu mais aussi
du collectif nous sommes les futurs
bâtisseurs du monde
moi je le crois une nouvelle citoyenneté
une nouvelle démocratie sont possibles
alors maintenant si vous voulez bien
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse une petite
expérience
j'aimerais bien qu'on se connecte les
uns aux autres mais pas avec nos comptes
facebook pas que nos téléphones tous
âges art bien qu'on se connectent pour
de vrai je vais vous demander de faire
quelque chose est ce que vous voulez
bien reprendre les mains vous prenez la
main vous voulez bien reprendre la main
de votre voisin de votre voisine super
on se prend l'avoir génial génial super
tout le monde a pris la main de son
rasoir de sa voisine génial génial
voilà on est connecté pour de vrai on
est des vrais gens on est vraiment
connecté
elle et d'accompagnement alors
maintenant qu'on est connecté on est
ensemble comme disent les africains
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse un rêve un
rêve ensemble j'aimerais bien qu'on
imagine le monde dans 15 ans on va
fermer les yeux et on va essayer de voir
ce monde là je vais compter jusqu'à 3 ea
3g vous demander de fermer les yeux 1 2
alors il est comment ce monde ton rêve
pour nous et pour nos enfants